[Music]
you gotta go make up the money yourself
or go get a job I fell in love with the
business because I realized it's a
people business and I thought well if I
get to do this for a living I want to do
is look at people talk to them smile
they smile walk away this is a great
career I have a weekly syndicated show
called now ethos with Rocco DiSpirito
where I help families overcome their
eating challenges I would love nothing
more than to go shopping with my time
and you know be epic the pika fashion
every day I'm not ashamed to admit I'm a
big fan of fashionable things what's up
everybody I'm Rocco DiSpirito and these
are my 10 essentials I love my Rolex
watch because it's vintage it was a gift
and the really practical reason is it's
kind of like cash on your arm if you're
ever in trouble you could use this to
get you out of country al-qaeda comes
this will get you out of a bind I like
to invest in a couple of classic pieces
like good shoes and the reason I chose
Ferragamo is because they're one of the
only quality brands that make a narrow
foot quality means lasting my favorite
black suit it's made by gucci it's a
very classic gucci look makes you look
really thin which is great that's what
you want something to slim you down
another one of my essentials is pair of
sunglasses and very specifically these
rape and Wayfarers tortoise color it's a
look that is always a good look to this
day I don't believe anyone makes a
better pair of jeans and Levi's they
have every cut you can imagine for
everybody just invest an hour and try on
several pairs and I'm sure you'll find
the kind that look great on you another
one of my 10 essentials is a vital pep
blender by the preppers only brand that
makes a blender that has enough power to
recreate the mouthfeel and coldness of
fat rich foods without using any fat
great way to start your day
another one of my 10 essentials is a
microplane grater or zester a very
clever carpenter decided his carpentry
tools would make great kitchen utensils
and boy was he ever right when you want
lemon zest you get just the zest
my mother's meatballs they're just so
good it's for meatballs if you happen to
be made healthy in this book that used
to be 250 calories each so you can
imagine how delicious they were
I've now turned them into 45 calories
each
and my mother herself has said that
they're better than her original recipes
another one of my favorites are from
Maison de Chocolat because they make not
only extremely delicious chocolates that
are all handmade and still made the
old-fashioned way they also make
chocolates with a hundred percent cocoa
no added sugar these are only seventeen
calories each but they're so delicious
you would never know that they were
healthy this is a scarf it's made of
cashmere cashmere has the ability to
keep you very warm and it's really long
the reason man should look for a long
scarf like this is so you don't have to
tie it like an ascot and look like a
character from Downton Abbey
those are my 10 essentials I think what
they say about me is that I understand
the balance between indulgence and
living a healthy lifestyle hopefully
you'll adopt a few for your own alright
guys this is how I tie a scarf but I'm a
chef so what do I know why don't you
tell me what your favorite accessories
are below or tweet using hashtag GQ 10
and subscribe to GQ cos they'll help you
stay man some guys that you want to be
Manson
[Music]